hey Chris hey Ben hey Morgan how are you
hey nice to see you uh Chris I'm so
curious what was it like getting a call
from Ben to be a part of this movie what
was your initial reaction oh it was it
was good I was excited because you know
Ben and I mean he's a great director
great actor and and Matt those guys uh
topped at the big dogs you know so I
always uh that's always a good call and
um you know they told me uh that um they
have a part not much to it and I was
like oh this you know I gotta have
something but Ben was like you know you
you could do whatever you want to do you
we're working out and I was like I
didn't understand half of what he was
saying but I said okay okay okay
and then I knew Howard white that made
it even better and I knew I can pull
from him but I didn't know how much he
was going to give me he gave me the
world about his life because he loved to
talk he had me talked about 30 different
people you know uh but since he was five
years old you know people he rode bikes
in the street with and played basketball
with and High School coaches and
teachers and up into Charles Barkley so
I had so much information it was so much
fun uh creating this you know I mean
just playing him and capturing his
Spirit yeah I love that well Ben
obviously hearing your uh Chris's
reaction I was just talking to Jason
Bateman he's like I didn't care what
this movie was I just knew Matt and Ben
were part of it so sign me up what's it
like hearing that reaction from people
I mean I came to I mean I I'm sure
they're lying you know because it seems
like they were I like to have to say it
but nonetheless I like that when they're
on camera they feel the obliged to say
something nice it makes me feel very
good I wish everyone was on camera all
the time when they asked about me
um I love it I'm proud these actors are
amazing I'm honored by really honored by
them being it I love that obviously you
and Matt have been friends forever you
guys were producing this movie you're
starting this movie together what is
your favorite thing about Matt as an
actor when you're directing
I mean he's just so
um good you know what I mean you it's
true like Mastery deceptively gifted in
that uh I think he's kind of I hate to
say like kind of underappreciated you
don't realize what a Sublime actor is
because it's so understated he's not uh
true in the first he's not grabbing for
attention he just has a capacity to find
the character and say the lines and have
it feel like completely authentic and
it's not a showy skill it's not Duncan
from the foul line but it's it's about
as rare really a gift that he's got such
a uh if and I didn't even appreciate it
until and I know the gun you know he's
my best friend and so I because I've
directed a lot of movies I've no one's
like to look at the footage and get in
trouble on the scene and go where do I
gotta go and always Matt's doing
something interesting always you have a
problem he bails you always he makes it
makes sense he's a director's gift oh
really all that this cast is yeah no and
you can you can definitely see that
through this whole movie it's so good
do you guys have a pump up song
obviously a lot of athletes a lot of
sports teams have a good pump up song
Chris you have one I know Chris has one
all music you know just a good song is
it's great I'll play a little Michael
Little Prince uh rap everything I love
music it stimulates your left and your
right side of your brain Quincy Jones
told me that
always with the great answer you know I
can't think of a song he starts hitting
up a bunch of things goes to Quincy
Jones Chris Jones best friend he knows
everybody knows the right thing to say
when I'm telling you when I grow up I'm
gonna be Chris Tucker I really am okay
so Ben do you have an artist in the top
of your head
Chris Tucker
[Laughter]
I love that Ben when you're directing do
you ever give motivational speeches like
your character Phil Knight
uh not quite like that but I that's
meant to be a little bit of a of a of a
kind of a parody because like that was
the it's not really making I mean really
it's a credit to Nike in a lot of ways
because they were the first company that
tried to you know express the idea to
people that were working for them but
hey we you matter to us and this is a
culture now in every store you know you
go in the men's room and it's like
you're part of the team and you're
important to us and like companies that
are just straight in business to like
you know um make you know widgets they
hire Consultants to be like what's our
missions what are our values do we care
about anything you know and they're
trying to think of like team building
and bringing it but they they believed
they were kind of hippie Marathon
jogging company in Portland outside the
mainstream and they have these set of
rules which was unusual for a company
like we have beliefs the whole idea of
the women you have beliefs your company
your belief is in the dollar is in like
yeah amazing profits and they they you
know they said hey if we do the right
thing we'll make money that was new
I love that well thanks so much guys
congratulations thank you thank you hey
Marlon hey Matt hi how you doing I was
just talking to Jason Bateman and Matt
he said I didn't care what the movie was
about I just knew Ben and Matt were part
of it what's your reaction to hearing
something like that
oh man you know we were so lucky to get
who we got is the truth and and what we
really ended up doing was hiring a bunch
of filmmakers you know like every one of
these actors you know like Jason you
know he directs he writes he produces he
acts Viola and Julius are A-list
producers on top of being great actors
Marlon and Chris are writers on top of
being great actors and so and that's
kind of what it required to build out
this Ensemble
um because we really relied on on all of
them to to really bring everything they
had to the to the project and and and
make it better than it was on the page
you know like we're big Believers in
um starting with the great script and
Alex wrote a great script make no
mistake about it but um but in in in
really uh casting great people and and
getting everything you can out of them
all those ideas and all that richness
and bringing it bring it to the story I
love that Marlon what was your reaction
getting the call to be a part of this uh
you know Ben called me up and I was like
I didn't care what it was you know just
the fact that you know it was Ben and
Matt I'm in it could have been a weird
you know adult film I'm like sure
that's the next one Marlin I was gonna
say I'll watch that
the cosplay let's go
let's go
I love that um I was just talking to Ben
about his favorite thing about umat as
an actor what's your favorite thing
about him as a director
uh he's really great you know I I I I
couldn't even limit it to one thing I
think the thing about growing up
together is you end up with the same uh
kind of taste you know the the same
things make you laugh the same things
move you I think Marlon can speak to
this too because he's worked with his
brother so much it's the same thing when
you're when you know somebody that well
uh you really are you trust them enough
to like if Ben feels really strongly
about something and I'm not quite seeing
it I'll just I'll just do it that way
because I trust him and I just you know
I I nobody has a monopoly on great ideas
and and so if he's feeling strongly
about something that's all I need to to
know to kind of all right let's pursue
that line of of thinking that you're
probably right yeah they have a
shorthand you know wasn't like a lot of
they they just kind of it was like
working with them reminded me of like
working with the Coen Brothers they just
kind of yeah you like it sure you want
to do another one yeah let's do another
one they just kind of you know we got
what we want they know what they want
and then they get it and then they get
extra because they make everybody else
feel comfortable and so yeah a a
playground you know it's like I just
walked in I didn't I didn't know those
guys I mean first of all they're from
Boston which is weird because I'm from
New York so I was feeling like not at
ease but then I walked in I was like oh
they got a little New York in them you
know I mean we're like you know I was
like yo we we people I love that uh
matter used to being referred to as the
Coen brothers with
do you hear them what do you know that's
what that's about as High Praise as
there is in in filmmaking uh but there
is uh Marlin's right there is something
that I always talked about that Joel and
Ethan would do that I really liked which
was
oftentimes one of them would come up to
me after a scene and say uh you know
give me a direction say like do it
faster and then a minute later the other
one will come up and say do it slower
and I'd say well your brother just told
me to do the exact opposite and
invariably the second one of them to
come up would say oh yeah do it how he
said so there was a real difference like
a deference to to how you know to the
people that you're working with and
going no I trust them like no they're
probably right you know yeah yeah I love
the music in this movie Marlon do you
have a pump up song
now I got pumped down songs I don't like
to get pumped when I go on stage I don't
I don't like to get pumped up right okay
I like I like to calm down I like to
just be ladies out throwing some some
jazz or something or you know just
something with no music at all I just
like to just sit and think and maybe
have like talk I don't like to I learned
I used to pump myself up and then when I
get on stage I'm like yeah and
everybody's like whoa where are you at
and it's just like it's it's too intense
so I just kind of like go on stage and
like feel out the crowd and just kind of
vibrate and create our own music
congrats on the movie it's so good thank
you thank you appreciate it thank you